you
[Music]
okay welcome everyone so we are very
happy to host sham Kaka D and another LM
sorry from Microsoft Research so we
spent four years in Microsoft Research
New England as the principal research
scientist and now is a professor in U
dub joint CS in statistics and you will
tell us about accelerating stochastic
revolutions great excellent thanks for
step inviting me and it's always good to
be back at MSR so the question we're
gonna look at today is you know can we
speed up stochastic gradient descent so
SGD is one of the most widely used
algorithms in practice and you know for
a variety of reasons it's used pretty
often it's very simple its incremental
and by that I mean mirror the problem is
we want to minimize some function f of X
we're trying to find parameters which
make this function value small and we
update these parameters in the direction
of some noisy estimate of the gradient
and the sargan is nice because it's
often very easy to cook up noisy
estimates of these gradients and it can
often be implemented in a streaming
manner and the streaming is something
we're going to be taking thinking about
a fair bit today because we don't want
to hold a whole data set in memory so so
this is you know is there a sense in
which SGD is optimal or is or can we
improve upon it and let's step back a
bit and ask this question about gradient
descent so gradient descent is this
algorithm where we just follow the exact
gradient okay and you know is there a
sense in which gradient descent optimal
or is there something better and you
know the answer is resoundingly that
there's something much better and
there's something much better both in
theory and in practice so in theory we
have these so-called fast gradient
methods like conjugate gradient heavy
ball acceleration BFGS and in practice
if you're in this regime where you can
compute the gradient
you would almost always prefer an
algorithm like conjugate gradient
because it's literally just as
complicated as gradient descent to
implement the same with BFGS it's like a
factor to more memory and it works I
mean it's ridiculous how much better it
works than gradient descent so in theory
in practice there are much better
methods than than gradient descent for
the same sort of memory and complexity
you're still restricting yourself you're
placing some implicit restrictions on
what we will also I guess this is so in
a sense if in terms of the theory
there's a precise sense in which it's
better and we'll come back to that
precise sense and in practice it's like
look we just want something that runs
fast so in fact this better means like
everyone would rather do something else
and that's always the case and in the
much happier doing something else for
the same complexity and in theory
there's a precise sense in which
gradient descent can be dominated okay
and we'll come back to them okay and and
now the question I look at is basically
we're going to sort of review a gradient
descent review how we can improve upon
it and then review stochastic gradient
descent and then ask a question so we're
just going to start populating this
table okay so the problem is you know we
want to we want to minimize some
function f of X we're going to review
what gradient descent gives us for
solving linear systems we'll review how
we can improve upon it we review the
stochastic setting and then we'll try to
phrase the question of how much can we
improve the stochastic method okay and
you know the punchline for this question
is can we improve it the short answer is
no and the precise answer is it sort of
no for stupid reasons and if we're
careful the answer I give is a very
strong positive yes so there we go
so no information content on that slide
so so the first part let's just go ahead
and review it and throughout we're going
to be looking at the basic problem of
solving a linear system or or minimizing
a quadratic objective function and you
know in many settings I could conjugate
gradient we designed an algorithm that's
very good for this problem and it tends
to work for a variety of other problems
okay and conjugate gradient is one of
these one of these algorithms so this is
our problem we're minimizing a sum of
discrepancies in linear equations so so
we want to minimize over X as a vector B
is a scalar
okay so this is we're trying to minimize
when d dimensions this is a basic
problem how fast we solve this okay and
n here is a typically much bigger than
the dimension like this this is not
necessarily consistent linear system
it's the questions about the setting I
guess we've got you know if n was D
we're trying to solve ax equals B and
that's not the and that's why I'm using
this notation
you know sophistic Swede often have why
W and X and here we have like you know a
is X and B is why that's just because
I'm using the you know the math notation
of solving ax equals B okay so let's
review gradient descent why is gradient
descent slow well it's slow for these
problems that are poorly conditioned
which is usually the problems we face in
practice so this is this picture is a
level sets of this function the
trajectory of gradient descent is
typically one where it'll quickly make
progress in one direction and then a
really slow down on this poorly
conditioned direction and the condition
number here is really a ratio between
how wide this ellipsis to how tall it is
it's the ratio between the largest and
smallest eigen values of the fish is
determined by a okay so you know in
picture is that's gradient descent it
behaves poorly when these level sets are
poorly shaped okay
so in terms of the actual convergence
rate after it so that's the algorithms
right because the gradient of that
function where we write a as a matrix is
just is just this this beast and this is
a problem which is converging linearly
so each time we do an update we're
cutting down our objective function by a
constant factor so great in terms of the
fact that we're getting linear
convergence but the constant in the rate
of linear convergence could be very poor
if it's ill conditioned so questions a
delta fixed yeah you you said it to be
like 1 over the largest eigenvalue of a
and then so is that it to be like 1 over
like the largest eigen value of a then
this is the ratio yellow juice okay and
it occur at a geometric rate so question
with that where is it bitter so what oh
so assuming you set the step size to be
1 over the largest eigenvalue yeah you
said to be a constant and you don't need
to decay it at all because if you're at
the right answer you don't move here if
to love you divorce so we're setting it
to be the correct value here we can get
this down as soon as the largest so we
do not know that this is sort of the
typical in in the literature that assume
we have the we set the parameters
appropriately not you Jim Atlantic
resolve eagle race all right well if you
said it to be one of the lambda max I
think this is exactly the sort of the
bounty routine define very slowly
so just question so what we get problems
why didn't you want to do this instead
of just inverting the matrix Oh
inverting that okay so this is a very
good question and we'll go to why if
you're asking this question then even
when I have a question is stochastic
gradients and why would we ever even do
that because that seems like even more
stupid than this thing okay so so in a
sense we're like going from solving it
properly to solving it something that
looks bad and then you guys pick asticus
and this looks horrendous
okay so inverting the matrix is cubic or
matrix multiplication time is the best
known okay so this thing if the
condition number is say constant or
reasonable the number of updates we need
to do to get epsilon accuracy is just a
log of 1 over Epsilon and every time we
do this this is possibly a cheap thing
to do in practice to compute in practice
to get the gradient so assume because in
many settings it might be cheap to
compute the gradient because it's a
vector matrix multiplication so it's
order a sort of dimension oh and yeah
it's order dimension so assume an is
about D for this so it's much cheaper
but if the condition number of starts
becoming like dimension or super linear
and the dimension then you know then you
might as well do the the exact a problem
and in a sense the game here is to try
to have the dependence on the condition
number as as good as possible because
that's the regime where we can beat the
exact solution okay and that's sort of
why this is critical because this is
still illegal where and you'll see yeah
the complexity of that is if you're
solving the linear system you could it's
sort of a sewer inverses and inverses of
the same complexity they're all the same
I mean in theory but we're not going the
exact computation right we're going cuz
of the stupid direction of going to
stochastic
okay so this is just review a vanilla
batch gradient and now the question is
can we improve upon this and now we're
going to classical results but let's
fill in this table so after n updates
where we're doing a full gradient
computation which is order dimension
computation this is our error okay and
now let's think about can we improve
upon the this this method and you know
in a more a general sense
you know not evenly what you might hope
to do is I'm seeing a bunch of previous
gradients maybe I could utilize my
previous gradients in a more clever way
to speed up the convergence okay and and
there's a sense in which you could ask
this question suppose I'm restricted to
live in the span of my previous
gradients which is you can be querying
for gradients and the point I'm going to
use is going to live in the span of the
previous gradients that occurred what's
the sort of best thing you could do and
there's a precise sense in which this
conjugate gradient algorithm is the best
thing you could you could use but
they're sort of a lot of functions
quadratic in this limiter is quadratic
there's a heavy ball method which you
can also have similar behavior and then
the develop this is celebrated result
for Nesterov on these accelerated
gradients but they're all methods which
try to beat gradient descent by sort of
living in the span of the previous
gradient okay and and it turns out at
the same sort of complexity like the
same number of gradient computations you
can really vary significantly beat the
gradient descent okay so I'll show the
intuition of the algorithm in a pitcher
but basically kind of like some kind of
momentum ish scheme but the main point
is you can improve the dependence on the
condition number to the square root
condition
and this is massive in practice because
you condition numbers like 10 to the 4
which is pretty common it's down to a
factor of 100 so you can shave off a
factor of 100 and this again sort of
bring up the regime for when these these
sort of interior pointage methods are
competitive with the exact solution okay
so conjugate gradient achieves this
certain extra acceleration okay and and
the key point is in practice these
methods are really the same
computational complexity and memory as
the gradient descent so they've you know
they really have the same weight and
then they work much better in practice
yes
actually just like a like number also
important heavy format so I never saw so
III I think they often referred to as a
fast gradient method so that that is
what I refer to as the umbrella term so
acceleration typically refers to a
Nesterov scheme but I think the class I
I think of them refer to refer to as
fast gradient methods avianna rows are
providing similar dox42
so the quadratic case all of them will
get this rate up their constant factors
so we are essentially saying oh yeah
there's a sense in which conjugate
gradient really is magical in that you
could sort of aspect what's the best
polynomial you know I think like
optimization and math people will say
there's a sense in which a conjugate
gradient really is the best bit because
you can phrase this this optimality
question more precisely but if you don't
care about constant factors they're all
kind of get to get this root rich at one
and let me give you a picture what's
going on because they're the tons and
tons of first of these things to of the
reverser got the experts in the room
here
jo-ann has a very nice food
this and so this has a different
actually pretty similar viewpoints but
here's kind of what's going to happen in
pictures so the gradient descent if you
start here you're going to quickly make
progress in this you know we've got this
function that's like this we're going to
quickly fall here and then slowly make
progress here
okay so we're making a lot of progress
in this direction but not very much
progress here okay so what we're going
to do with these fast gradient methods
or at least like this acceleration
scheme is we're going to sacrifice
progress in this direction to make more
progress here
so think about adding like a momentum
term if you the first step you're going
to really quickly the first few steps
you're really going to quickly fall into
the valley okay grating a sign at this
point you'd be done you just sort of
move slowly here the fast gradient
methods well they're going to be like
wait wait wait I'm going to keep my
momentum and continue moving up in this
direction okay and then I'm going to
continue moving up in this direction I'm
going to bounce around and sway into the
region you know what that's going to do
is we're actually losing progress in
this direction but we're making more
progress in this direction okay and and
if you think about it that's why this
analysis tricky because this is like
this if your game theory arguments and
polynomial arguments but they really are
sacrificing progress in some directions
to make more progress in the other you
kind of like putting lots of energy in
your system to say go go go and you're
kind of bouncing around a lot more in
these large directions but the hope is
we're still going to get pushed back but
it's delicate because if we push too
much will diverge in this direction okay
and we clearly have memory here because
you know where we moved here is not just
a four here not just a function of where
we're at it's a function of the path we
got there okay so we are in fact
utilizing the previous gradients and but
it turns out you can do this in a way
that's not very memory intensive you
don't actually have to remember all the
gradients you can just keep track of
like some running averages okay so
filling our table in
very understand this is the accelerated
scheme you can replace capo with root
campus so both are still linear but this
improvement is very significant and
these algorithms often work extremely
well for even non convex problems okay
so now let's go to stochastic gradient
so questions about this this is just a
review okay so we're good of stochastic
gradient the concern for these methods
is the kind of unstable when you do
stuff like this because you're really
you know the game is I'm trying to move
faster in this direction and if I used a
much larger learning rate you know a lot
of your learning that would be great for
making progress in this direction but if
I just did that I would diverge GTD
other direction so that's why these
methods are tricky because they're
somehow trying to effectively use a
larger learning rate in some directions
but you have to do this in a way so you
don't diverge okay and and that leads to
you know even when you run one of these
methods the pictures seem kind of crazy
okay so this is the deterministic
simulation I just got this off someone's
blog the blue line is the performance of
gradient descent this red curve is SGD
so this is iteration this is log of the
function value difference between your
function value in the optimal function
value so both are kind of converging
linearly but the the rate is much better
for the acceleration scheme but it's not
improving the performance at every step
it looks kind of unstable and you know
as many people try if you just add a
little noise into it often times it just
goes completely haywire where's gradient
descent is stable the repeats are
hundreds of changing sources no these
are actual constant step sizes for the
acceleration scream it's a review to
this like overshooting business
and that is sharp kept this point of
shine right what's that yeah yeah yeah I
mean just like just simulating like
momentum or something like that like in
a toy example it's sort of clear that
something's are caught
oh this is just kind of the minus seven
so yeah
it really goes down to minus infinity
yeah or and that's a really good line
would be converging yeah the point is
like these pictures are pretty generic
when you run it and guaranteeing
function value convergence improvement
is tricky as you point out it's your
paper is saying look you don't sort of
guaranteeing function value convergence
at every step is pessimistic both of
your papers explicitly point out that
you should use some other information so
so that's basically beautiful is this so
I understand so the move on eventually
pull down this row or is it below right
okay just a lower so I'm sure linear but
it's all but the main point is like
these things they're kind of notorious
they unstable in terms of the classical
in numerical analysis there's a lot of
papers when we talk about if you heard
of like line shows method it's basically
conjugate gradient for eigen vectors and
you know any numerical analysis textbook
is always like make sure you have enough
bits of precision in in memory or things
will go haywire okay and these are sort
of deterministic questions but in a
sense our game is we want to do
something quick and dirty it's going to
be noisy what's going to happen like can
we actually get these improvements and
this is a pretty important problem
because in practice we do do these very
noisy algorithm and and now you're going
to ask the question why would I use an
algorithm even worse than the gradient
descent in practice because that around
you know it's not doing the exact
solution and this comes back too
the reason that in many of the sort of
machine learning problems we do it
actually we're not sort of doing rocket
science or engineering we're trying to
we're trying to get estimators of things
in the world that a fundamentally noisy
so getting the twentieth digit of
precision my matrix who cares if you
know if I got like a hundred samples or
something like that okay so I mean here
we have more than a hundred samples but
the point is we don't want numerical
accuracy and and the key point is that
we never released a machine learning we
never care about solving the problem ax
minus B because that's on the data we
have we care about minimizing some
unknown objective function so now we're
going to move to that second column we
look at SGD but the problem there is we
don't want to solve the problem X minus
B we want to solve this problem where we
have a distribution over vectors a and
scalars B and we want to find the minima
X if we knew the distribution we could
state this as again a linear system
problem but we're only going to get
samples of a and B pairs so again this a
is the vector this B is a scalar I want
to find an x which minimizes this if I
knew the function this is just a
quadratic okay but it isn't but I don't
know the function so I'm only going to
get these these sample values another
question is what is you know how well
can we solve this problem and if we
didn't care about computation this is a
sistex problem okay but we care about a
sort of computation as well okay and and
in practice this is why SGD is is very
good because you know we're going to
just do gradient descent but get some
quick and dirty estimates of our
gradient and we're not going to converge
to the right answer very quickly but on
the other hand I sort of the fact that
it's noisy there's only a certain amount
of accuracy that's justified by our data
okay so but but now this is the problem
we want to solve and we're in an Oracle
model where we can get
say these A's and B's pairs sample
randomly under the underlying
distribution the questions about the
setting okay
so now let's look at this algorithm
stochastic gradient descent okay so now
we have some parameter X we're going to
update a parameter based on say one
sample okay so you can just move in the
direction of some noisy gradient so
rather than following the gradient of F
we're going to get some unbiased
estimate of the gradient where so an
expectation will be correct gradient
descent for this problem you know
there's a question of how we adjust the
learning rate do we turn it down so on
and so forth but this is a sample of our
gradient if we have if we have the
current parameter vector X T this is X
minus B times a so this is a vector and
this is how we updating okay so this is
vanilla gradient descent it turns out
there's this very amazing result of poly
a Kinji disagree and it says that if you
use a constant learning rate well if
they don't use a constant but basically
it says if you do gradient descent and
you keep track of a running average of
your parameters in the limit that is
statistically the best up estimator you
could use okay so so so forget so forget
about for a moment the computational
problem okay so if I get a bunch of data
there's a question of what's the best
statistical estimator
all right instead of stations to think
about this and by and large it's like
you know take the sample minimizer right
if I want to measure a bunch of heights
I get I have like a hundred thousand
people the best estimators use the
empirical mean on the data I've seen and
that really is a you know there's a
strong sense in which that's the minimax
estimator okay
I know general distributor
for any distribution that's why this
result by Polly action Judas key is
really a limit theorem they were showing
that if you do gradient descent
appropriately and keep track of a
running average the distribution of the
the point you your learning who is
actually going to be the same as the
maximum likelihood estimator and that's
sort of mini max optimal so it's a very
strong it's not even just you're getting
the best rate of conversions the actual
distribution of your estimator matches
the distribution of the maximum
likelihood estimator yes hopefully I got
more surely it's almost Rory alright so
but you know the purpose of this talk
you know forget about the convergence of
the distribution if we didn't care about
how fast this kicks in this is a very
strong result saying why SGD is such a
good estimator because it says if we
have enough data this quick and dirty
thing eventually is going to look like
the best statistical estimate okay so
this is now central to how the number of
the number of steps that you make is
your sample so it's sort of information
theoretic quantity that you know I have
to pass through my data set one and this
says in one pass you're going to get an
optimal statistical estimate okay so
it's a strong the very strong result
yeah basically it's the same kind of
assumptions not just our distribution
it's the same kind of assumptions in
statistics where you get these kind of M
estimator basically whenever you can say
the maximum likelihood estimator is
optimal under those assumptions this
thing kind of applies this slide can
suits the others under the rug okay so
let's let's be concrete
and specialize it to this request
problem in the special case where the
noise is additive it's more general than
this but suppose the value is B we see
suppose this is the true distribution
that those there's some distribution
over B and a but it satisfies this
property again we don't know X star okay
and this is what we want to minimize
with n samples the best weight you could
get for this problem is the dimension
times the noise level of the problem
divided by n with n samples okay and
Sigma squared is that noise oh this
really is the best so I think about in
1d what is this in 1d it says the rate
of convergence is the variance divided
by n okay so this is really the limit
theorem and there's nothing better you
can do and having a constant that's much
larger than this is terrible because
this constant is real like we want the
variance in the problem okay so this is
just statistically the best estimate if
you just do like sort of poor SGD
implementations you won't get this but
if you if you do the iterated Everage
then you'll actually get this rate that
there's a you know there's a question of
this little of one and that's kind of
critical okay the random samples already
it's already that's right and that
expectation is in F this expectation is
the fact that our samples are noisy so
so we're running so think of like
measuring a mean my amount I'm off from
the right answer is the variance over N
and expectation and that expectation
with respect to the samples I received
right because I could I'm not going to
be correct on every path but in
expectation I'm correct and with
stronger you know stronger bombs we can
say with high probability but this is an
important point an expectation this is
the best rate and this is true for large
enough ass in the waiting speaks bullies
noise yeah
this is like just you know the most
written by the statistics from and Kenny
capitalized for this one can you save a
and be fair once more and get say noise
or the noise is a random variable so if
I look at the same a and if I look at
the same a again I'm going to get a
different D but the difference between B
and a X star is sampling from say a
Gaussian iid this just did a simplified
assumption you can generalize that so
for Sammy I can get these relative
you're getting every time you you get an
A I'm going to get given you noise and
add to it it's just living a lie
separation model happen sort of my
mother's video slide the basic here okay
Julie step sizes are constant and then
uses are averages are moving floor and
lower yeah but we keep the point moving
to that yeah that's right yeah that's
right that's right so in the prior to
this so I'll give you the precise rate
if you keep the constant step size that
seems pretty good in the very zealous
you actually decrease the sub size and
did averaging but for this case the
right algorithm is you know use a
constant step size and begin averaging
some point in time in the future because
you don't want to advocate from the
beginning but but but that's exactly the
right intuition that's sort of a you
know keeping your steps as large is good
because you're really moving in
expectation in the right direction but
the averaging says you're going to kind
of get rid of the noise okay so let me
just give you so let's just you know the
short answer is when we think about
gradient descent or stochastic gradient
and there's two parts of the way to
think about it there's um you know in
expectation we're moving toward the
right answer and there's going to be a
part which depends on where we start the
distance between where we start and we
end up right because we start somewhere
and we start far away from the right
answer it's going to take a long time to
get there okay but there's also going to
be a part that has to do with the fact
that our problem is noisy okay
that you can think of as a variance part
okay and if you run gradient descent
kind of appropriately the stochastic
gradient is an appropriate way you can
get the following convergence rate okay
so the the lat so after n updates of
stochastic gradient descent and you do
an average averaging you get the second
term which is d Sigma squared over N
which is great because this is exactly
the statistical rate okay then we get
this first term which is kind of looking
like we didn't have any noise like this
vanilla gradient descent bound okay and
you know this constant Kappa has a
slightly different definition so think
of Kappa here as you know it's like the
analog of the condition number but for
the stochastic case so for those
familiar with the literature let's do
the simplified assumption that say L is
a upper bound on how large these vectors
are okay so this is also irrelevant like
nature's concentrate concentration like
how big your vectors are and let's say
mu is the minimal eigen value of this a
of a transpose matrix and Kappa is going
to be the ratio of these two quantities
so so basically for stochastic gradient
descent there's like a bias part in the
variance part the bias part depends on
where you start okay it's dropping
exponentially which is great but this
variance part which is you know a sense
information theoretic okay so this is
the bound on sort of stochastic gradient
descent okay and I so let's fill in a
stable now we're getting its to actually
for savage extreme jumping constants I
don't know how to and I'm how to drop it
from two with the constant step size on
but we can talk about the constants
great a lot okay so the casted gradient
descent its behavior looks a lot like
gradient descent but we pick up this
extra very and and of course this Kappa
the definitions a little different
so and you know this is really one of
the most led they used algorithms and
the key point is you know the
statistical part we can't improve upon
an SGD but who cares because that's
information theoretic but there's parts
that depend on where we start and and
that's what we might hope to improve
upon and now you know this question of
accelerating SGD we can think about it
is you know we still want to get the
optimal statistical estimate but how
fast can we kill off the bias I don't
want to somehow improve the bias at the
cost of sacrificing variance I really
want to make this as small as possible
and you know that naive conjecture is
like look looking at this table I'm
going to just sort of replace capital
with rude camera that's sort of what you
expect with these fast gradient methods
and that's the naive thing you might
hope for okay so the question now is you
know can we accelerate stochastic
gradient descent a hip would you talk
about long version of the simulation it
was right over an oil and I won't
explicitly talk about that you can kind
of think about what happens if you just
like adalah I mean this mood case you
just add a little noise like but yeah so
formalizing that we haven't done yet but
we know how to kind of think about that
that's it okay and so the question is
can we beat it and the root Kappa would
be amazing if we really could do it
because these algorithms are just much
much better in practice right and SGD we
never use the previous gradients well
momentum we we put put in a little in a
stochastic a case it's less quick isn't
clear how much that helps okay so how
much you know what can we hope for here
okay so in terms of you know previous
results there's only been a lot of work
arguing that the sauce gradient methods
fundamentally not robust to noise
citizen work by Nesterov and Co and
desperat again those are not statistical
and there's been a lot of work in
surprisingly that you know even Paulie
in his book looked at a stochastic
version of conjugate gradient with
simulations in the 70s and arguing it
was unstable it was unstable to noise
and so there's been a fair bit in the
numerical analysis literature looking at
statistical issues LAN has some very
nice work for accelerating in a
different Oracle model but he can't
actually explicitly analyze the variance
term and show it's optimal and you know
and there's a there's a string of
results more recently for optimizing for
better solving the the consistent linear
system when we have a set of equations
but the real thing is we want you know
we want to understand a sistex question
of what's possible and just like these
old numerical linear algebra questions
like when they ran things they you know
poly X result and some of the other ones
we're suggesting this variance term was
higher and that would be sort of
disastrous from an estimation
perspective okay so the question is can
we find a way to accelerate this thing
and what might that even look like
because even that isn't know I can't
even achieve this root Kappa okay so you
know naively if you just think about
this the short answer is that this is
not at all possible just sort of due to
stupid reasons and let's look at one
stupid reason so suppose our aid our
standard basis vectors so so as a
vectors of this one here 0 1 0 0 0 so so
there's a 1 in the is coordinate and and
I'm going to the distribution is such
that you see descent the I ascend is
basis vector with probability P i okay
so it's not too hard to convince
yourself that the condition number of
this problem is one of our P men because
you know that a transpose matrix is
diagonal and the diagonals are the
probabilities and you know that
conditioner was 1 over P MIT okay so in
gradient descent you know kind of needs
to run weather condition number of steps
before anything non-trivial happens
and you clearly can't beat this because
if I don't see all the basis vectors you
can't get a non-trivial statistical
estimate you have to at least wait
around until you see all the dimensions
because before that happens you can't
say anything non-trivial okay but once
you wait that amount of time you waited
one over P min so you waited a order
condition number a number of samples
okay so at that point you could say look
well you kind of can't beat this phone
because this phone says look for
something non-trivial to happen I kind
of have to get about Kappa samples and
this is just unimprovable it's not a
computation it's just information
theoretic okay so so naively um well mmm
we're done you can't be that shitty okay
so we're placing capita the woot kappa
would be crazy okay that's the short
answer and so let's look at one more
example where when you see this you
realize something fishy is going on so
aside from the distribution on on the
standard basis vectors another nice dish
you should think about is a Gaussian so
suppose a comes from a Gaussian
distribution okay so a comes from n 0 H
because H is the same either u transpose
ok here the condition number is going to
be the condition number of the matrix H
ok so this is like you know we're
getting samples from some say poorly
conditioned ellipse so the Gaussian
distribution like covariance matrix is
very poorly conditioned so you can have
an example where this condition number
is just as bad as the previous problem
okay but if you think about this
Gaussian example there's no problem
information theoretically after you see
about D samples from the Gaussian you
have a good estimate of what this
ellipse looks like it's like it's you
know you think of it with this notion of
spectral approximation but the point is
get about order D samples from a
Gaussian look with that sort of shape
looks like it basically looks like the
underlying distribution okay and that's
is true regardless of how sort of bad
this
condition number is okay so so for
Gaussian once you get about what are
these samples information theoretically
you can definitely start getting good
estimates okay but SGD is going to be
really bad in this case because if
someone has just you know measured your
coordinates stupidly they measure in
terms of kilometers rather than
millimeters or something like that and
you run this algorithm you're going to
get burned so here like
information-theoretic we were fine but
we're just running this algorithm say in
some terrible coordinate system okay so
in this case we really might hope to
improve upon things because information
theoretically we could do better and we
could just plot these two cases for the
behavior of SGD so so this is a log log
plot so this green curve is sort of this
D Sigma squared over n this is you know
what the best information theoretic
estimator looks like it kicks in and for
the discrete case at around you know 10
to the 4 is samples because that's when
you see all the directions that's when
you get a good statistical estimate and
SGD is kind of garbage but then once you
start seeing all the directions that
really starts dropping down very quickly
to the green line okay but in this
galaxy in case I started up exactly with
the same condition number information
theoretically once you get about a
hundred samples because in 100
dimensions then you know the year you
have a great information theoretic
estimate because I just solved the
linear system exactly but SGD is taking
forever before it starts sort of kicking
in because it's really you know it's
poorly conditioned so this is the case
you might hope for improvement but in
the left one we can't but in terms of
these parameters they're identical
because the you know the condition
number is the same for these pumps the
ocean of so the deficient memory is not
the condition number of the covariance
matrix or something like that a sort of
a bit of a like on yes so so I be in
condition
so um so kappa for the gradient descent
problem would be the sort of the max
over men of the matrix for the
stochastic version is going to be more
exactly it's going to be more like the
sum of the eigenvalues divided by the
middle that's that's exactly right so
and in fact you know technically I said
it was how you know so that's we like
how large your vectors are and that's
how large is a square norm of your
vectors are which is like the trade
that's exactly like I'm kind of soothing
that distinction under the but that's
that's quick it's critical if there's a
refuge for the patient's small any
desperate or Becker from ever life yes
small a is a sample from what small is a
sample from the underlying case we've
got this problem and there's a
distribution of vectors in these we're
just getting samples of them one to talk
okay so we'd like to say we can get an
improvement in this case they're the
case on the left is it we're basically
optimal so so now we have to think
statistically because this condition
number the way we've defined it is
coordinate dependent and we want a
notion of how how the problem
statistically is that doesn't depend on
coordinates okay and you know that's
like a sometimes people call this a
leverage score but let's just define it
and then I'll give the main result so
yeah so now going to your point that the
condition number that determines the
performance of gradient descent is is
roughly a bound on how big your vectors
are compared to the minimal eigen value
of that matrix so the Gaussian is
something like trace over lambda min
okay and and this is sort of standard in
the sort of optimization literature okay
but what determines the the search
mystical complexity and the way to think
about that is how many samples you need
before you get a good approximation to
your covariance matrix so that I mean by
you look at your empirical estimate the
covariance matrix and you want that to
be upper and lower bounded by the true
covariance matrix okay and basically
from these matrix boons Berenstain sort
of arguments what matters isn't just how
big a is in an arbitrary coordinate
system its how big the vectors a are
under the covariance of the problem okay
so suppose this thing is bounded by
Kappa twiddle okay so here I make a hard
upper bound assumption you can relax it
in terms of movement properties but the
point is this quantity is invariant to
coordinate transformation and morally
for a Gaussian okay so technically is
infinity but it's basically dimension
for Gaussian is how big the vectors are
under H inverse is the dimension and you
can formalize that okay and how big this
quantity is for that discrete
distribution it's one of a payment that
you have to clinch yourself about other
okay and this quantity capital is an
information theoretic quantity which is
how many samples you need to get an idea
of what the lips of your data looks like
and once you get this many samples
you're going to get a good statistical
estimate okay so and and for this
definition capital is 1 over P min so is
Kappa so they agree but for the galaxy
in case Kappa twiddle the dimension and
that could be much much better than the
coordinates in your problem okay so now
the main result so those of you familiar
with some of these results from sums of
finite optimizing sums of convex
functions like some of the results that
ju-hwan has I can kind of guess what
we're going to get here so the
improvement now is we can't replace
Kappa by root Kappa but we can replace
it by the the Kappa times Kappa twiddle
again Kappa twiddle is sort of easy to
see a strictly less than Kappa
so this is a strict improvement and you
can discuss it more offline but my claim
is this really is the right analog of
acceleration you know for those familiar
with these results like gluten kappa in
the finance um literature this is kind
of the right improvement here ok and and
this is a strict improvement and
importantly we have an algorithm which
we don't sacrifice on the Cystic irate
so we really get like a constant here
for the Cystic away this isn't some
worst-case upper bounds it's just going
to zero it's you really are getting the
right and optimal statistical estimator
for your problem and you're strictly
improving upon the bias term and in
terms of the main theorem what's
important about this is this is an
algorithm you can do this entirely
streaming you don't have to remember any
of the past gradients it's a run time is
actually exactly the same as SGD it's
like twice as complicated so it really
is a streaming algorithm I the bias you
strictly improve upon it the variance is
just as good as SGD and you know there's
it's a pretty simple algorithm so I'll
come to in a second actually this is the
LG envisioning to do that so some of so
though you have to argue about how to
finance some problem relates to the
statistical problem and I know if if n
is bigger than Kappa twiddle that's one
matrix constant so so first you have to
relate for how large your sample size
needs to be before it even before you
even generalize and that has to be some
multiple of Kappa twiddle right so
that's sort of the key and then how do
you set Epsilon so you can get this with
sort of log n passes to your data set
but but then you really have to store
everything in memory and the argument is
really about solving your offline
problem exactly and how odd is that
generalize to the underline
tribution in a sense this is the whole
point of Leon mbutu's in those guys
paper and there's a ysgg is good and why
Pagliacci this ski averaging is good
because we shouldn't be going through
the kind of numerical version to the
Cystic immersion but I think you know in
practice the reason I like these
Oracle's is it's very hard to store
things in memory even if we saw a data
set in memory like you think of image
net or something like that every time we
touch an image we jitter it like and the
same thing with this music data set is
constructed it really is continuous time
and we're dropping in that in practice
no one ever on these large data sets we
rarely store other variables like could
we really do want to run in the
streaming model okay but this suggests
you know least for the square lost case
we can improve upon it but the algorithm
is pretty reasonable just so your things
that you really are actually so in this
Oracle model there are cases where
people are actually winning something
that is a traditional thing does never
run down somewhere and I'm saying in
practice on many of these big clubs that
really is the case because when we take
for example will often do some random
transformation of it or like my music
data set I really have in continuous
time and even though I've stored my
whole data set I'm kind of jumping into
a random integer and and we really do
run our algorithms a large class of
algorithms around in this Oracle model
so I think it's a helpful obstruction to
where they work in that Oracle model now
just looking at this toy example we want
it and yes we're exactly the same in
this Bernoulli case even just looking at
the behavior the algorithm will come to
it we'll see it's the same but in this
Guardian case we get what we expect
again this is a log log plot so this
improvement is pretty significant like a
factor of 100 and it's exactly what you
might hope for okay you'd like to do
right here but we don't know it how to
do that without doing a matrix inversion
but it does seem to get us right in the
geometric mean between where we might
hope to be and where we are and this is
D that's where we might hope to be
there yep this square the cup a cup of
chilled also made you sound so my
conjecture is yes we were sort of
arguing about how to write that I'm with
Michael but to the extent that there are
the sums of convex functions where you
have this root and Kappa I kind of view
that as the the analog I think it'd be a
nice question to figure out how much
where philosophic question is yes I
think III I think that that's a great
question too but I think that's you know
so what I'm interested in okay so partly
I'm interested in theory but partly like
I want algorithms that work in practice
that I can really speed up and it is
this weird picture than in the exact
land will never use gradient descent
it's just completely dominated by VF GS
and conjugate gradient and as a
stochastic land we have nothing
analogous to this aside from momentum so
you know part of this was just I want
something that's in practice that works
in practice I think it's interesting
extending it to other functions waiting
is also a great question for how do we
you know how do we get things that work
well in practice I won't go through the
details of the proofs because you know
part of it is very clean there's another
part which you really have to just
understand this as a stochastic process
because that's what in a sense SGD is
and you just have to blast that out and
that was pretty hairy the algorithm is
actually pretty cool in that I didn't
write this in the paper we should update
the archived version and I think there's
a different intuition which I'll explain
now suppose we're doing gradient descent
okay so great so it's a gradient ascent
with the constant step size of 1 over L
that would be like the largest
eigenvalue that would be this update so
forget about this hat ok so suppose I'm
doing like just just getting intuition
I'm doing gradient descent ok and I'm
using say some large learning rate sorry
I'm using the learning rate I can use
for the exact use ok so now for a moment
suppose you are watching me and you're
looking at where I'm going I'm going
descent and hypothetically what you're
going to do is every time I'm at a place
you're going to look and see where I
would have gone had I taken how to use a
much lower learning rate so I'm just
doing like vanilla gradient descent and
you're watching me but instead of like
using my learning rate you're just going
to ask yourself look if Sean like took a
much used a much larger learning rate
where would he have gone okay and I look
at this over time again let's suppose I
just keep track of a running average of
where would I have gone had I used a
much larger learning rate okay now if
I'm running this thing for a while and I
ran it for like a thousand steps and you
keep saying look every time I'm wanting
to move if I just cranked up by learning
rate I'm getting pushed in the same
direction I should probably be moving in
that direction right because somehow if
I like somehow if I'm making progress
my gradients should be going to zero
right if I'm my gradients seem to
consistently keep pointing me in some
direction I probably should be moving in
that direction okay the problem is I
can't just sort of crank up my learning
rate because I'll diverge but you could
somehow so the idea now is think of like
the gradient descent update that's this
what you're going to hypothetically do
is think about taking a much larger
learning rate at every step so this is
that step some top step in the past
consider what happened if you if we use
a much larger learning rate okay and
what I'll do is keep track of a running
average of what would happen if I had
used a much larger learning rate okay
and what's that meaning where I move to
you so this is so this is a forget about
this so if I if I just and that some
parameter X T suppose I add my gradient
with a very very large learning rate
this is just the result of that update
yeah each point I'm at the task I take
one step look where it goes and I keep
track of a running average of where that
is where that's pushing me to
you know yeah and the point is like if
this thing is it the current point I'm
asked then chances are like I should be
mixing this into my current update right
so somehow it's like suppose I wasn't
doing this mixing you're just watching
me and my gradient sort of keep pushing
me somewhere else I probably want to go
there because if things have been
working migrating this would be zero so
the idea now is to just try to simulate
what would happen if I use a larger
learning rate so this is just a one step
update if I take a large learning rate I
can't just use the larger learn a lot of
urghhh
but I could keep a running average of
this and then slowly mix this in okay
and you can keep track it's just a
running average - the point is you can
update it contacts delay so there's a
conjugate gradient you're using the
history of all your gradients when you
make an update at time T but you can
store this compactly so what you're
keeping track of is you know your update
is this is a gradient descent update but
we're mixing it in with some kind of
running average of where we would have
gone in the past had we take in use much
larger learning rates but we're decaying
it off and just like conjugate gradient
this momentum is you know we're going to
be sacrificing in some directions
because look for some of these
directions I shouldn't be using a
learning rate this big because I'm
overshooting but the point is by doing
this running average you know
yes I'm overshooting but I'm going to
get pulled back by this guy somehow so
this is why you know acceleration is
this delicate game that I'm losing
progress some directions to to improve
it on another and the point is with
noise it turns out we can show this as
noise stable so we actually use constant
learning rates average and and then you
just do this log of the arithmetic and
it works a lot but the algorithm is very
sensible
how t-minus is that you're waiting of
earlier things heavier Oh probably my
stage yeah probably just ignore the math
I just listen I'm thinking words like I
can um yeah keep my toast oh no I think
it it really what I was doing and you're
discounting got a reminder okay okay and
I how many t is between journal tell - t
ya when tau is 0 we tell our doer this
is correct because then I'm mixing in
then I have that the most weight on it
you should be commenting t know it's
right when tau is 0 it's a quick reading
today okay so what is what to you is
once even saying the record why my cases
anyway hopefully there's no way yeah
Brazil TX which are average of YT o we
kind of average of X DX
yeah there's no wise here so I'm just
writing this and then I returned the
running average of these guys so you
don't have to pinky right one is all
shooting quick yeah and then you have
decaying average yeah yeah see a little
bit of water orbit each one of them play
or yeah so the reason is that if I just
use this large learning rate some of the
directions I'm going to completely
overshoot I think of this Valerie I'm
going to completely overshoot in that
direction so I can't use this right now
but the point is if I overshoot a little
or even a lot
I'll get pulled back by gradient descent
so the point is it's like what I'm going
to do is you know overshoot a bit by
keep pushing in the direction I want to
go but I'm going to pull myself back for
the large directions by gradient descent
and that's why I like these acceleration
analyses like a super hairy to do this
is because um you're actually suck you
know it really is the
argument where you're sacrificing
progress in some directions to improve
it with other directions and you know I
can't just use some modulating rate
because I really will diverge and it's
running average like this running
average is kind of the time scale in
which I'm going to allow myself to pull
myself back from overshooting and speed
up in these smaller directions so this
sort of a sort of larger the step size I
want to use here for these smaller
directions that also means the larger
the time scale I'm going to need to use
because I'm going to be your home gonna
swing back yeah the giant area so the
you will will control how they are like
the magnitude of my swinging yeah that's
right the fail will control
counterweight yeah and the new reset
because if we have some small eigen
direction the flatness that's like the
learning that I want to use in that
direction this is how much I swing back
but the point is this beta now has to be
statistical because it's sort of
averaging at a rate in which I see this
smaller direction because I don't get
exact radius so and the key point is I
can always make data you know even if I
use some insanely large problem like I
tried this on some deep learning pub and
I used like a learning that here ten
thousand times as big as the one here
and I made a stable by just decaying
slowly enough which i think is great in
practice because we need a way to be
very aggressive and still make it stable
and this gives us the the right
parameters to control at controller oh
yes we would exactly yes thank you
recover the leader acceleration I yes we
do recover the waiter said I think the
interesting question is suppose those no
noise and we're solving a set of
consistent linear equations so but it by
no noise I mean a gradients are so
random because I'm only getting kind of
rank one I'm only seeing one equation at
a time then we're converging
geometrically and that's sort of an
in-between case okay so it's actually
this is let me just show you the next
plot
so this one I think it's very revealing
so now I'm going to assume that B is
always a X okay so every time I get an
equation but my entire infinite set of
equations has one solution like a
consistent solution so here you would
expect geometric convergence because if
you're at the right answer you don't
move okay and so there's notice the
Sigma squared here is zero okay and the
exact arguments don't work because their
updates are rank one okay and this is a
plot of iterations and this is the log
error it's very interesting here is that
so this and I think this is very
compelling that this algorithm really is
much better because this is the simplest
case you can consider and what we're
surprising to me is running Nesterov
scheme and just vanilla momentum really
does be gradient descent momentum we see
improves in practice as well so this is
a gradient descent you're converging it
you know linearly and the slope is the
condition number you run momentum or
Nesterov scheme and we're surprising is
we did a grid search to find the right
parameters and both were right on top of
each other so momentum and less rough
scheme were identical definitely much
better than gradient descent but they're
tying two parameters together basically
this beta parameter isn't being set
right and this extra degree of freedom
means this is this algorithm and it's
really striking the improvement and and
this is not some pathological example
this is just solving linear you know
linear equations does anyone find out
any kinds of extra parameters to
momentum for you know crazier things
like these running because I guess a
whole a whole bigger personally of
momentum you seen yes yeah that sounds
like that's exactly the interesting
question I tried this and okay this our
super toy and I'm trying to do it more
thoroughly because the real question is
you want to be more aggressive but sort
of the you know they kind of million
dollar question here is is it going to
be stable because these methods somehow
are insane if you think about what's
going on
and but once I rewrote the equations
this way I felt like it shouldn't be
that hard to set the parameters because
I can really make this guy some large
multiple of this one but I know I should
be able to make the running average
consistent because if this is small
enough I'm just mixing in an average of
a good point right because I can
basically you know for any large
learning rate
I can effectively make the running
average so slow that it should be stable
and I want to try this out and it seems
one it seems super stable that you know
the way you tune the parameters is push
you choose the learning rate for a
gradient descent just however you did it
before then you crank up some large step
size like use maybe like a thousand
times as big or ten thousand times as
big okay now you're going to diverge and
you just crank down your window size
till things are stable again and this is
so instead of you know how do we you
want SGD we set the parameter so we
don't diverge and now we just have to do
this for two parameters okay and I've
been starting to play around with it and
it seems okay so the caveat is when I
first did this I thought well maybe
momentum is just doing this okay and
then for awhile I was convinced that we
just didn't know how to prove momentum
was good but then Rahul just simulated
the thing and would praneeth and we saw
a massive difference here and we're like
no no this really does dominate momentum
like if it if it's happening here and
we're doing the grid search this extra
parameter is really crucial here so I
think you know in terms of some summary
and some of the open questions is this
acceleration question you know I think
it really is possible in this stochastic
land where we can strictly improve the
bias and really get the same optimal
statistical variance and you know in
terms of theory I think there's an
interesting question of you know is a
lower bound this is some analog of like
the the chebyshev sort of argument as to
what the best you could hope for is for
just say solving an infinite set of
linear equations where you could just
stop with them randomly and I think the
practice one is a
you know these simulations were at least
the momentum owners in the last week it
was a very compelling reason that
momentum you know momentum and
acceleration it's all kind of the same
in the deterministic land but in the
stochastic land wine it's stable and -
it's not like we're just saying the bode
algorithms we had are good we're
actually losing a degree of freedom when
we use momentum and if we add that in we
could actually significantly improve
upon it proved upon using momentum and
the question is how much do these really
help in you know like non convex
problems as well even just broader
convex problems and this is joint work
with a number of partners in crime much
of a mess our folks that have been
working on working with for her prints
and fatigue were awesome and then Aaron
have been working with these questions
for a while and then you know the lion's
share of the analysis was with with the
student at UWL Konami which is really it
was really pretty amazing analysis like
in the sense that learning these
analysis that once you figure out what's
going on there's no potential function
that can that can analyze this problem
cleanly you really have to understand
this as a stochastic process and like
provably we can show that there's no
scalar potential function which is show
up enough to do the analysis whereas
these you know deterministic versions
you can always do the analysis sort of
an upper bound on how good how much
progress you've made but in these
settings you actually have to look at
the like the full variance covariance
matrix of your your process and I think
that's a very revealing because they
aren't just upper bounds like their
analysis
we're actually characterizing like the
true behavior in a problem dependent way
of a problem and we can sort of exactly
write everything out in terms of for
moment properties and by we like this is
basically as well so thanks
I would go to the math page right there
and come you the heck parameter right
you have considered formulating that is
actually the function how the numbers
that's not your step sizer projecting
right especially in a burly really
protects she - how far back that go with
the parlor is going to be probably most
likely right from your ear if you do
that you almost don't have to make data
also Senate oh yeah I mean I think in a
sense you don't want to because because
so suppose you in the linear system and
things you could just adjust this
coordinate at that time step you know if
I want to solve 2x equals 1 for whatever
X I'm at I want to use a learning root
of 1/2 not a function of time so this mu
is basically solving the direction find
me the X such that new x equals 1 okay I
always want to use a step size of 1 over
mu and it doesn't matter where X is for
that direction I would jump to the
answer in one step with one overview not
true for well problems it has a
generally quadratic rows but it probably
doesn't not fair to us yes that's right
but in terms of the statistical
estimates yes so I think there's a there
is a question of the more general case
for how to do this but in terms of you
know things like momentum and what we
run in practice like look this is
probably true for momentum to yet you
just set this as one parameter
regardless of how crazy
the problem is Detroit exactly this on
the logistic regression but it also acts
it does everything
I mean I tried this on M this with
values and IQ levels the values of the
heavy
so anyway stable so yeah sure but I mean
yeah like asymptotically well I think
the main question going to practice is
we I felt like I want to skate the
algorithm in a way it's clear we can
adopt the parameters to
get stable just like momentum and this
formulation is very clear to me it's
pretty stable compactive except you had
a chance to basically compare with to
happen judging based might look like an
allylic to see actually okay I think
yeah Adam at a delta in a sense they're
incomparable and my feeling is in a lot
of settings of those methods are really
a disaster because they're kind of
mixing up two things that the rate at
which you turn down the learning rates
they just get completely wrong because
they're just ad hoc turning down and
stuff and some at some rate but I'm
saying like yet but they but they that's
why they kill you when stuff like on
some vision problems you're just turning
down the learning it's way too fast now
in terms of the diagnose scalings
for some problems where we believe the
covariance matrix you know can be better
conditioned in an access aligned way and
then they're good that's only some
problems and for those it's easy enough
to run those with momentum or this
scheme but they're really incomparable
because you know like in a natural
language processing problem I kind of
know that my words a special coordinate
and I don't need to use a demur at a
delta in these problems I could
literally just scale every coordinate by
the variance in it and that has the same
effect so I think there's a reasonable
question of how to combine this with
these sort of I do I view them as like
pre-conditioner methods but but I think
the issue with Adam and added Alta is
they really will kill us on on a number
of like often computer vision problems
because they're kind of actually turning
down the learning rates too fast and
like even just like a square loss
problems I can you know I've tried it
out and it's very clear they're coatings
on the learning rates too fast so but in
terms of combining it with them that
it's easy enough to combine
momentum methods with preconditioners
you're just using the long steps with
the same thing that Adam and added otter
are doing the learning rate so fast
becomes the number of updates on the car
because kids actually so fast so they
actually they have to like that anything
like this this is false because just
look at like a locally quadratic problem
which is often like a reasonable
proximation this is like totally the
wrong thing to do the reason like this
really is the wrong thing to do because
they're turning the learning rates down
way too quickly in those problems I
think the the reason they're working
isn't so much turning the learning rates
down in fact they're learning in spite
of that the reason they're working is
you know some features are very rare
because their access the line and the
scaling up the learning rates for those
for those features and this is something
I'm trying to do just explicitly
understand the curvature in in your
problems and figure out better ways to
do it but but I think separating these
two things is actually like it would be
a valuable thing to do but we can chat
about it oh okay all right let's thank
them again
[Applause]